لا تصدعوا رؤوسنا ايها الامريكان
فالامر لا يستحق اكثر من ضغطة زر
واحدة هكذا اعلنت روسيا وواشنطن
ترد باسلحة قوية لوقف التقدم
الروسي في اوكرانيا. فهل تنجح
بذلك? الولايات المتحدة تبدأ
مصادرة الاصول الروسية لشراء
اسلحة لكييف. والقوات الروسية
تقطع شريان امداد القوات
الاوكرانية تودد للرئيس الروسي.
الاستخبارات الامريكية تعلن عن
موعد حسم الحرب الاوكرانية.
والمنطاد الصيني يخر سريعا ليظهر
منطاد اخر في امريكا اللاتينية
وواشنطن تودد تركيا والسبب
بوتين. بينما الكونجرس يبتز
تركيا على مرأى ومسمع. كندا تصوت
لصالح الاقلية المسلمة وفرنسا
تستقبل **** بحفاوة.
الرد الروسي لا يتأخر. الزحف لا
يتوقف والقصف يتواصل وكل شيء يتم
تدميره وشيئا فشيئا يقترب الروس
من اهدافهم شرق اوكرانيا. حيث
يعلن زينسكي ان قوات هناك تعاني
من شدة الحصار وكثافة القصف
وبدون سابق انذار واشنطن تقدم
مقترحا للسلام. فما هو ردكم ايها
الروس المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ديمتري بيسكوب ان التقارير بشأن
عرض الولايات المتحدة على روسيا
عشرين في المائة من اراضي
اوكرانيا كاذبة مضيفا امن شبه
جزيرة القرم مضمون ونسعى لتوفير
الحماية الكاملة لدومباز. اي انه
يقول لدينا اكثر مما تعرضون فيا
لعرضكم المضحك. وبعد ان اعلنت
كييف خطتها لاستعادة شبه جزيرة
القرم ياتي المدد الامريكي.
ولوقف اي تقدم روسي اعلنت واشنطن
انها ستقدم لكييف مساعدة عسكرية
اضافية بقيمة مليارين ومائتي
مليون دولار تتضمن صواريخ دقيقة
التصويب يبلغ مداها ضعف مدى
الصواريخ التي تستخدمها كييف
حاليا ضد القوات الروسية. ما
يمكنها من استهداف الخطوط
الخلفية للقوات الروسية ومخازن
الذخيرة من خطوط التماس. ويصل
مدى هذه الصواريخ الى المقاطعة
الاربع التي اخذتها روسيا بما في
ذلك شبه جزيرة القرم. يا الهي هل
اقتربت النهاية? الخطوط الحمراء
يتغير لونها لتصبح خضراء في عيون
الامريكان. ولكن مهلا مهلا هنا
الرد الروسي ياتي سريعا حيث صرحت
القيادة الروسية بانهم في اتم
الاستعداد بيد من حديد اذا شنت
اوكرانيا اي هجوم على القرم
وسيكون هناك هجمات مضادة وستتحول
باقي الاراضي الاوكرانية التي ما
زالت تحت سيطرة كييف الى رماد.
كما قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ديمتري مدفيد بل انه هدد
ايضا بتوجيه ضربة انتقامية
باستخدام كل انواع الاسلحة بما
فيها النووية وبما يتناسب مع
تهديدات ليعلنها ميخائيل شيريبيت
النائب في مجلس الدومة قائلا ان
اي محاولة للقوات الاوكرانية لشن
هجوم صاروخي على شبه جزيرة القرم
يعتبر اعلانا للحرب من قبل
الولايات المتحدة مضيفا انه قد
حان الوقت كي يدرك السياسيون
الامريكيون الجاهلون قبل فوات
الاوان ان المزاح مع روسيا وصخب
السيوف سينتهي بشكل سيء. واشنطن
الى حرب اخرى من الضغوطات
والعقوبات على موسكو. حيث اعلنت
وزارة العدل الامريكي اجازة اول
عملية نقل لاصول مصادرة من احد
رجال النخبة الروسية المعروفة
بالاوليغارشية الى وزارة
الخارجية، وذلك لاستخدامها في
دعم اوكرانيا. ومن حرب العقوبات
الى معارك الرصاص والدبابات. حيث
تخنق روسيا اوجليدار امدادات
اوكرانيا ليعلن الجيش الروسي انه
احرز تقدما في دونتشك وقطع
العديد من طرق الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانية في بلدة
اوغليدار. اوكرانيا ترد بمناورات
بالدبابات في منطقة تشيرنوبل
المحظورة قرب الحدود مع بلروسيا.
ومسؤولون اوكران يشيرون الى ان
المناورات جاءت ردا على
التدريبات العسكرية الروسية
البلاروسية. هناك الدفاع الروسية
عن تدمير رادار امريكي الصنع
وقتل مائة وسبعين جنديا اوكرانيا
بعملية للجيش في دونيتسك. بينما
تبادلت اوكرانيا وروسيا ما يقرب
من مائتي اسير في عملية اعلنها
كل جانب. وتضمنت اعادة جثتي
متطوعين بريطانيين الى كييف. حيث
اكدت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
الافراج عن ثلاثة وستين اسير حرب
لدى بواسطة الامارات. هنا سنصمت
قليلا. ليعلن الامريكان عن موعد
حسم الحرب. حيث اعلن مدير وكالة
الاستخبارات المركزية الامريكية
ويليام بيرلز ان الاشهر الستة
المقبلة ستكون حاسمة للغاية في
حرب اوكرانيا يتزامن هذا التصريح
مع تأكيد قوات انها تعاني في
دومبس شرقي البلاد. ليدخل
المستشار الالماني على خط لكن
بغرابة هذه المرة. وبعد دعمه
لكيه بالدبابات قال انه من بين
القادة القلائل الذين يحافظون
على التواصل مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين رغم الخلافات بين
البلدين في ظل الحرب المستمرة في
اوكرانيا. مضيفا ان ابقاء خطوط
التواصل مع الرئيس الروسي يهدف
للبحث عن مخرج من الفوضى. نحن لن
نعلق على ذلك وسننتظر ذات الردود
نعم انها الخالة فرنسا فرع روسيا
ونقصد هنا بكل تأكيد ماريا
زاخاروفا. حرب البالونات
الصينية. من اقاصي البحار الى
الاجواء. التوتر الصيني الامريكي
يدخل طورا جديدا. بايدن يطالب
باسقاط المنطاد والبنتاجون يرفض
لتعلن واشنطن ان كل الخيارات
ممكنة ووزير خارجيتها بلينكن
يؤجل زيارة الى الصين. وبكين
تقول ان ارسال منطاد للتجسس تصرف
غير مسؤول وينتهك سيادة الولايات
المتحدة البنتاجون من جانبه ينفي
ما ذكرت الصين. ان المنطاد الذي
دخل الجو الامريكي لم يكن
للتجسس. وشدد البنتاجون على انه
يراقب المنطاد عن كثب. بينما قال
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
انه اقترح عدم اسقاط المنطاد
خوفا من مخاطر فاي توتر واي
ارباك سببتها بكين للامريكان
بهذا البالون وبعد ان حدثت كل
تلك الفوضى ها هي واشنطن اخيرا
تعلن اسقاط المنطاد الصيني قبالة
سواحل كارولينا الجنوبي. بينما
يستمر اصحاب العيون الضيقة
بمفاجأة الامريكان ليعلن
البنتاجون مرة اخرى عن رصد منطاد
تجسس صيني ثان يحلق فوق امريكا
اللاتينية الذي تحمله مناطيد
وبالونات اصحاب العيون الضيقة يا
ترى. ومع انشغال واشنطن
بالبالونات. هناك تقارب يبدو
منطقيا. نعم. انه ذلك الذي تشهده
العلاقات بين الصين وروسيا في
الفترة الاخيرة. بل خصم واحد
والتنسيق امر حتمي كما تراه
الدولتان لتعلن الصين انها
مستعدة للعمل مع روسيا لتنفيذ
شراكتهما الاستراتيجي. تركيا بين
مطرقة امريكا وسندان روسيا.
العجلة تدور والزمان يتغير. لكن
يا لسرعة تبدل حال الاتراك. وبعد
ان كانت انقرة تملي شروطها على
واشنطن صارت واشنطن هي من تمارس
ضغوطاتها المكثفة وبقوة على
انقرة لكبح علاقاتها مع روسيا
بحسب بلومبرج. وهنا تحذر وزارة
الخزانة تركيا من مخاطر فرض
عقوبات على انقرة جراء التعاون
التجاري مع روسيا. فانقرة تغذي
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا. وذلك بتصدير
مواد كيماوية ورقائق دقيقة
ومنتجات اخرى الى موسكو يمكن ان
تستخدمها في مجهودها الحربي ضد
كييف وفق قول الوزارة الامريكية
لتضيف انها قد تتحرك لمعاقبة
الشركات والبنوك التركية التي
تنتهك العقوبات. الضغط الامريكي
لا يتوقف. لكن هذه المرة دعا
عشرات الاعضاء في الكونجرس
الامريكي للربط بين صفقة اف ستة
عشر لتركيا وموافقتها على انضمام
السويد وفنلندا للناتو وتركيا
ترفض هذا الشرط وتريد من البلدين
اتخاذ موقف اكثر صرامة من حزب
العمال الكردستاني. فمن سيستجيب
لطلبات الاخر? الاحداث
والتطورات. صوت البرلمان الكندي
بالاجماع لصالح توطين مسلمي
الايجور في قرار تاريخي لحماية
الاقلية المسلمة في الصين ولم
تصدر السفارة الصينية في كندا اي
ردة فعل بشأن القرار. ماكرون
يستقبل رئيس وزراء الكيان
الاسرائيلي بحرارة ويجدد دعم
فرنسا الكامل للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي. حزب العمال
البريطاني يجبر النائب كيم
جونسون على الاعتذار بعد قولها
الحقيقة عن فشية الاحتلال
وانتهاك حقوق الفلسطينيين.
تيارات اسلامية وهيئة مهنية
سودانية تعلن رفض التطبيع مع
اسرائيل. فهل تستجيب حكومتهم؟
روسيا تهدد امريكا باستخدام
نووي. بينما لا تحتاج الصين
لسلاح خطير لتخيف الامريكان بل
يكفي بالون واحد او اثنان. فيا
للعجب! بقى.